ja willkommen zur heutigen Vorlesung
heute machen wir nochmal einen kleinen
Rückblick zum Thema künstlichen
Intelligenz und praktische Philosophie
das ist ein zentrales Thema praktische
Philosophie und Digitalität Digitalität
bedeutet die lebensweltliche Realität
der Digitalisierung
digitale Technik ist nicht mehr nur an
Randphänomen ein Spezialistin
Spezialisten Bereich ein Bereich der
Technokratie sondern digitale Technik
trinkt einen unseren Lebensalter in
unsere Lebenswelt und verschmilzt mit
ihr wir binden
reibungsfreien nahtlos verschiedene
digitale Medien in unseren Lebensalltag
ein und generieren daraus eine ganz neue
Kultur ein Handlungsraum Virtualität
kommt bekommt eine viel größere
Bedeutung dadurch und das nennt man
Digitalität ich mache oben rechts links
rein zu einer Vorlesung die ich gehalten
habe über Philosophie der Digitalität
wer von ihnen die Sache sich noch ein
bisschen genauer anschauen möchte
wir haben dann so ein bisschen gefragt
handeln wir wenn wir Computerspiele
spielen Computer spielen man spricht
auch manchmal von digitalen Spielen
digital Games die Folien finden Sie
jetzt alle auf Indias schon und auch
alle Zusammenfassung und Sie bekommen
heute von mir auch noch alle
Zusammenfassung gebündelt in einer PDF
mit Inhaltsverzeichnis sagen als eine
Unterstützung für ihre Lernsession die
ja ab heute Nachmittag dann beginnt das
ganze Wochenende sich bis Montag 14 Uhr
erschrecken sind ja klar
inwiefern können Roboter und künstlich
intelligente Systeme wie z.B Chat GPT
handeln und da haben wir eine Umfrage
gemacht handeln wir Computerspielen und
70% haben gesagt ja und 30% haben gesagt
nein natürlich wie immer sind solche
Fragen philosophisch problematisch lösen
ganz genau erklären was sie geglaubt
haben will was ist Computerspiel was ist
ein Computerspiel und so weiter und so
fort hier geht es auch nur darum erst
Intuitionen einzufangen
und viele die Mehrheit von ihnen sagt ja
wir spielen da schon und tun auch was
und Handel ist nicht nur Konsum oder
sowas sondern es ist wir sind Zwecke die
wir verfolgen es gibt handlungsvoll Züge
es gibt Realität die eine Rolle
virtuelle Realität zum Beispiel
dann möchte ich jetzt noch einen kleinen
Nachtrag machen man muss zwischen
starker und schwache künstliche
Intelligenz unterscheiden das wurde mir
gestern auch noch nachgetragen das ist
eine wichtige Unterscheidung ist und
kann ganz allgemein sagen schwache
künstlichen Intelligenz simuliert nur
Intelligenz Leistung besitzt zum
Beispiel kein Selbstbewusstsein keine
Autonomie und schwache KI realisiert
Intelligenz Leistung also nicht nur
Simulation und damit gehen dann häufig
auch kognitive Zustände ein her mentale
Repräsentationen Dingen sie an diese
Debatte um den Irrtum
dann können sich auch solche Systeme
irren sie können wirklich vernünftig
genannt werden bisher haben wir es nur
mit schwacher KI zu tun
man spricht doch häufig von genereller
KI generell die dann wirklich alles kann
aber wenn sie sich Chat anschauen das
hat schon eine gewisse Generalität ne da
können Sie beliebige Dinge Fragen nicht
nur auf eine Hinsicht ja sie können zum
Beispiel sagen programmiere mir mal
bitteschön das Programm für diesen Zweck
und so weiter und so fort und spuckt in
das Programm den Quellcode aus dennoch
kann man nicht sagen dass das eine
starke Form von KI ist weil es noch viel
zu beschränkt ist und in der Forschung
ist völlig umstritten ob es überhaupt
irgendwann mal starke KI geben wird oder
sowas mit Selbstbewusstsein sogar es
gibt viele gute Argumente dagegen das
soll ja auch nicht Thema sein weil das
ihr Thema der Spekulation ist die wollen
hier ist ja nur uns auf diese schwache
KI konzentrieren als auch Phänomene die
wir gerade tatsächlich beobachten können
und wollen schauen wie könnte diese
Phänomene angemessen beschreiben mit den
Begriffen die wir hier auf unserem
Begriff Netz haben alle im Kopf
natürlich deswegen darf ich das betrifft
eine Zeit zwei Vorlesung schon gar nicht
mehr an die Wand weil Kopf haben ist ja
klar
völlig überflüssig von mir und jetzt
möchte ich noch mal ein bisschen was zu
aktuellen Bedeutung von schwacher KI
natürlich sagen künstlichen Intelligenz
KI und ml ist maschinelles Lernen
Stichwort maschinelles Lernen das ist so
der absolute Trend momentan also KI wird
in ganz verschiedenen Bereichen des
Alltags eingesetzt Computerspiele wenn
sie gegen den Computerspiel Gegner oder
die Gegner den Spielen wird KI
eingesetzt wenn sie Medizin studieren
oder dann mal als Ärztin tätig sind auch
da wird zum Beispiel bei
Krankheitserkennung immer mehr bei
bildgebenden Verfahren immer mehr
künstliche Intelligenz eingesetzt ja bei
MRT oder CTS und so oder die neuronale
Netze drüber äh Text Erkennung wenn Sie
Texte ausfraktur Schrift in lateinische
Schriften wann wollen überhaupt Bild zu
Text Erkennung da muss er neuronales
Netz sich hier sagt gleich noch ein
bisschen was neuronale Netze drüber
laufen
Spracherkennung wenn Sie Google oder
Alexa haben da muss natürlich ihre
sprachliche akustischer Input als ein
Muster interpretiert werden was am Ende
sprachlich ist und auch in der Kunst
spielt künstliche Intelligenz immer mehr
eine Rolle da komme ich heute auch noch
ein bisschen drauf zu sprechen ich habe
bald eine Diskussionsveranstaltung über
die Frage kann KI Kunst erstellen und
falls ja ist diese Kunst schön das ist
ein Thema eine andere Vorlesung im
Zentrum stehen
GPT habe ich schon mal genannt also die
geben wirklich instruktive Antworten ich
greifen auf Milliarden von Daten zurück
sind sogar Billionen ähm das Problem ist
wir können nicht mehr nachvollziehen wie
der Chatbot zu seiner Antwort kam genau
und das beschreibe ich nachher noch ein
bisschen präzise durch die Struktur des
neuronalen Netzes die dahinter das heißt
man kann sagen es ist eine bloß
simulierte Kommunikation es ist keine
reale
aber auch da kann man natürlich aus
philosophischen Sicht noch viel dazu
sagen und künstliche intelligente
Systeme schwache KI wie Jet GPT die sind
keine handlungssubjekt im String sind
denn die bekommt die Ziele von außen
natürlich kann es sein manche geben sich
Ziele von ihnen aber in letzter Hinsicht
muss das System gestartet werden es muss
programmiert werden natürlich können
Systeme dann auch selbst was
programmieren aber diese erste Impuls
dieser Zwecksetzung das überhaupt was
entsteht die muss von außen kommen wie
kann man interessante Vergleich auch zu
uns Menschen ziehen das ist noch mal
mein kleiner eine kleine Kommunikation
mir war mal langweilig und dann hat mir
Chat GPT 9 gute Tipps gegeben die hier
folgendermaßen aufgelistet sind sie
können selbst mal eingeben dass sie im
Chat sagt was sie machen soll wenn sie
langweilig ist wenn sie werden sehen
identischen Antworten ausspucken das ist
zum Beispiel ziemlich wichtig wenn es
immer Diesel Antworten ausspucken würde
wäre das ja nichts anderes wie so ein
Art Lexikon oder so ja nie danach
schlagen kann aber so ist es halt nicht
es ist viel komplexer jetzt habe ich
schon gesagt künstliche Intelligenz kann
ihn ganz verschiedenen Bereichen
eingesetzt werden und jetzt gehen wir
mal hier auf die Kunst ein alphago ist
und nicht direkt Kunst das ist ein
Programm was dieses go Spiel mit KI
erstellen lässt und ein Schach praktisch
ein Schachspieler also go ist noch viel
komplexer als Schach mit sehr vielen
Steinen mit sehr komplex vor allem
asiatischen Raum wird das gespielt und
noch viel komplexer und da hat
tatsächlich auch die KI den besten
Go-Spieler besiegt und die hat sich
sogar so das Go spielt beigebracht dass
sie gegen sich selbst gespielt hat es
ist auch interessant da hat man zwei
Kies gegeneinander antreten lassen und
die haben dann damit alle Regeln gelernt
schach ist es genauso es ist sehr
beeindruckend und auch in der Kunst
schon mal was mit
kreativ genau das ist auch open ai
Dolly to is a new system
bei description natural language das
heißt sie geben da was ein Sprachbefehle
und es spuckt ihn dann was aus was
dieser Aufforderung entspricht so wie es
eben auch im Fall von Jet GPT die Tipps
waren wie ich meine Langweile besiegen
kann und jetzt habe ich folgenden Befehl
gegeben diesen System
malen impressionistisches Ölgemälde das
einen Roboter mit einer roten Blume in
seiner oder ihre Hand zeigen stellen
sich mal über vor wie würden sie das
sich vorstellen als impressionistisch
das heißt musst du getupft sein
portilismus ein bisschen muss sehr viele
lichtschatteneffekte haben sie sie
kennen sich bestimmt besser aus mit
Impressionismus als ich und jetzt
schauen Sie mal was mir dieses System
ausgespuckt hat das hier und das finde
ich schon ziemlich
bestens ich habe noch einen Entwurf
ausgespuckt den fand ich aber zu
expressionistisch nämlich so sah der aus
ja also das ist für mich eher schon ein
bisschen
expressionistisch und das hat für mich
diese Schattenwürfe diese krellen
Flächen sie kennen bestimmt dieses
Gemälde dieser Kathedrale kennen Sie
bestimmt diese französische pressionist
wo die Kathedrale aus ganz verschiedenen
nicht Verhältnissen gemalt ist und so
scheint mir das auch zu sein das finde
ich schon ziemlich interessant sage ich
jetzt mal ja man kann jetzt drüber
diskutieren ist es tätig was ist tätig
ist das schön hängt natürlich immer
davon ab was was schön ist ja normative
Bewertung Stichwort Normativität wollen
wir gar nicht jetzt weil diskutieren ich
finde nur die Ergebnisse nicht trivial
bedenkenswert aus philosophischer
Hinsicht hier kann man noch viele
interessante Gedanken sich machen sollte
aber auch nur hier ein Beispiel sein
natürlich kann man sich jetzt ein Ethik
der künstlichen Intelligenz überlegen
gehört aber eigentlich auch nicht so
dieser Vorlesung kann sich fragen ist
künstlich Intelligenz ein Subjekt kann
sündschutz Intelligenz handeln die Frage
werden heute auch noch ein bisschen
behandelt besitzt künstliche Intelligenz
Intentionalität ist das System gerichtet
und zwar geistig gerichtet auf etwas ist
die autonom setzt sich selbst Zwecke
und das diese Fragen ein bisschen besser
verstehen zu können müssen wir in die
Geschichte der KI-Forschung etwas
eintauchen und mal zurück zu den
Anfängen gehen Erlen Touring haben sie
alle schon mal gehört die
touringmaschine den Touring Test schon
haben Sie bestimmt auch schon mal gehört
und Huber greifuß haben Sie vielleicht
auch schon mal gehört in bestimmten
Kontext alle diese drei Dinge haben sich
auch mit Computer und künstlichen
Intelligenz fast das ist ja einen
Touring der hat einen Aufsatz
geschrieben
Computings
also 1950 schon ziemlich lange jetzt und
gesagt wir sollten die Frage kann
machine think ersetzen durch die Frage
gibt es vorstellbare digitale Computer
die in diesen Imitation Game gut
abschneiden wird Imitation Game darauf
müssen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen
genauer eingehen haben Sie vielleicht
auch schon gehört die technischen game
was ist denn das eigentlich gibt es ein
Szenario so sieht das aus habe ich aus
Wikipedia genommen es gibt hier eine
Person und die soll erraten ob sich
hinter einer Wand ob hier ein Computer
die richtige Sache sagt oder eine eine
wirkliche Person also dieses Symbol hier
ist entweder Frau oder Mann und beide
Computer und die Person hinter der Wand
muss der Person C äh die überzeugen dass
sie ein Mann oder eine Frau
ja also es ist praktisch geht um ein
Imitation der Computer muss so gut diese
Person B imitieren können dass Person
sie glaubt da hinten seit tatsächlich
eine Person nicht nur ein Computer also
letztendlich der Computer soll uns
simulieren oder imitieren dass sie eine
echte Person wäre ein Mann oder
eines wie auch immer das war dieses
Setting damals geht um die Imitation und
also hier wird künstliche Intelligenzen
und im Gesichtspunkte Imitation
betrachtet ja also wenn der Computer ist
genug im tiert wenn wir wenn er den
Imitation Test sozusagen sie können auch
die Touring Test ja wenn er dieses
Imitation gehen gut gut spielt da eine
gute Leistung hat und uns täuscht und
uns die Sache so gut imitiert dann
besitzte Intelligenz das ist natürlich
ein bisschen problematisches Kriterium
weil das ist ja ziemlich relativ ja also
ob wir jetzt das als wirkliche Person
halt oder nicht das hängt von uns ab die
wir uns überzeugen lassen und es müsste
sich in viel mehr Hinsicht entscheiden
als uns nur täuschen zu können als das
Imitieren zu können da ist es noch recht
reduktionistischer Begriff von
Intelligenz und John sirl hat das noch
etwas weiter verfeinert hat ein Aufsatz
geschrieben kein Computer singt und er
hat
hier unterschieden zwischen Syntax also
der
regelgerechten Anordnung von Zeichen
oder Symbolen
und zwischen Semantik Semantik ist die
Bedeutung von zeichnen ja Syntax ist
diese logische Ordnung zeichnet
Manipulation Regeln und Semantik ist die
Bedeutung was wir darunter verstehen und
er sagt jetzt Computer
besitzt nur Syntax Regel logische
Operatoren und so weiter und von diesen
Regeln der Syntax kommen wir nie auf
diese Mantik nie auf die Bedeutung und
zwar
definitionsgemäße Computer haben nur
Syntax und können die sensibel für
Semantik sein es gibt sagt er weiter no
way that assistant der Computer kann
Geld from text es gibt zu einem Kluft
von der bloßen Anordnung von logischen
Zeichen was da alles im Computer vor
sich geht da gibt's Logik Gatter haben
Sie vielleicht schon Strom kleine
angeschlossen
gibt es Halbleiter und so weiter und
dann wird da fließende Stromflüsse durch
und dann wird was berechnet nach
gewissen Regeln das ist alles das was im
Computer stattfindet aber wenn der
Computer ein Bild ausgibt oder sowas hat
er natürlich keine keinen Sinn für das
Wasser ausgibt da kann es nur berechnen
wenn man kann eigentlich gar nicht
wirklich sprechen dass er oder sie etwas
tut thinking sagte ist Mord and just a
matter of
maniculatings
denken geistige Zustände sind mehr als
nur des manipulierendes ordnen nach
syntaktischen Regeln von bedeutungslosen
Symbole
semantische Inhalt als ich Bedeutungen
Assoziationen
begriffsunterschiede alles was
letztendlich auch mit kognitiven
Zuständen zusammenhängt das ist was was
uns Menschen auszeichnet vielleicht auch
andere Lebewesen aber der Computer der
kann das nie erreichen weil der immer
nur Zeichen manipuliert nach gewissen
Regeln aber sich gar nicht fragt nach
der Bedeutung das Bedeutung ist für ihn
letztendlich völlig irrelevant kann und
deswegen sagt jetzt schon sehr es
handelt sich dabei nur um Simulationen
those Features bei Definition der
Computer ist unable to duplicate how
ever powerful maybe is ability to
simulatorication and simulation and nose
Simulation Bike ever constitute
duplication Computer können nur
simulieren sie können nur so tun als ob
sie eine Bedeutung hätten man kann das
jetzt noch weiter beziehen auf unsere
heutigen Themen als ob sie etwas malen
wird als ob Sie einen Begriff und einen
Sinn ein Gespür eine ästhetische
Eingebung hätten von impressionistischer
Kunst genauso der Chatbot der mir
geantwortet hat auf meine Frage was soll
ich tun wenn mir langweilig ist der hat
auch nicht die Bedeutung der Frage
verstanden der hat einfach nur da was
gerechnet er hat ein Algorithmus
angewendet der hat da
wahrscheinlichkeitsverhältnisse
berücksichtigt und dann kam das raus
das war letztendlich Produkt von
Algorithmen von
Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilungen die ein
Muster eine Muster besonders gut in
sprachendem Eingabe ein Antwort musste
auf mein fragemuster könnte man sagen
berechnet anhand von Milliarden von
Daten Punkten aber verstanden hat der
Computer oder Jet GPT deswegen meine
Frage nicht und ich muss ihm deswegen
auch nicht dankbar sein oder ihr oder
wem auch immer dafür dass er das hier
ist mir eine Antwort gegeben hat weil er
gar keine Gründe hatte keine
menschlichen nachvollziehbaren Gründe
wir eine Auskunft zu entscheiden es wäre
sozusagen absurd sich zu bedanken bei
jett weil GPT gar kein Intentionen hat
keine Emotionen hat keine Gründe hat
warum er oder ist mir hier die Antwort
sollte wenn Sie mir eine Antwort geben
auf eine Frage dann sollte ich mich
einfach bei ihm bedanken oder ich sollte
ihn dankbar sein
wenn sie mir dabei helfen diese Fragen
nach Dankbarkeit die sich in der
Kommunikation eigentlich immer stellt
die wäre hier zumindest nach schon sirl
fehl am Platz wir diskutiert da auch
noch gleich beide das ist ganz
entscheidend hier also er sagt KI oder
Computer können immer nur
definitionsgemäß anhand des Begriffs von
Computer immer nur simulieren sie können
nie duplizieren oder realisieren
Duplikation würde bedeuten der Computer
simuliert nicht nur dass er ein Bild mal
simuliert nicht nur dass er meine Frage
versteht und mir Antwort gibt sondern er
gibt mir wirklich eine Antwort er
versteht mich wirklich auf einer neuen
Ebene so wie man sich eben in Science
Fiction Szenarien solche Roboter
vorstellt dass die tatsächlich das
machen sie kennen sicherlich den data
aus ähm
Enterprise so solche Androiden Figuren
da gibt's jede Menge in Science-Fiction
Literatur und das sagt jetzt schon
begrifflich aus dem Konzept heraus ist
das gar nicht möglich dass er etwas
realisiert oder dupliziert sondern nur
Simulation ist möglich ich gehe jetzt
gleich noch durch und noch durch noch
eine Geschichte der künstliche
Intelligenz und dann diskutieren wir
darüber noch Treffen
der nächste den ich behandeln möchte ist
Hubert reifuß und dieses Foto habe ich
sogar selbst zu ihm aufgezeichnet und
danach auf Wikipedia gestellt ja weil
davor gab es noch gar kein Bild von ihm
drauf und er hatte Aufsatz geschrieben
mit seinem Bruder
brain artificial intelligence back at
the French point
wir unterscheidet ihr jetzt zwischen dem
was ein Geist auszeichnet der meint und
der Modellierung eines Gehirns sie ahnen
schon um was es geht es geht
letztendlich um künstliche neuronale
Netze er nennt das Konnektionismus er
hat schon im Jahr 1964 hier etwas
geschrieben
alchemy and all the Fisher intelligence
also Alchemie und künstliche Intelligenz
interessanter Begriff der Alchemie und
wollte Gold herstellen im Mittelalter
aus verschiedenen Metallen das waren die
Alchemisten finde Vergleich dann ein
nächstes Buch aus dem Jahr 1972 Wort
Computers kannst du limits of artificial
telegens das Bild ist natürlich
sprechend da wird einfach den Computer
der Stecker gezogen und damit war es das
dann auch schon
okay und dann hat er noch mal hier ein
neueres Buch geschrieben im Jahr 1979
Bordcomputer still card to equity of
artificial reason
Frage wenn ihr zu über 3 Fuß noch leben
würde er ist leider vor einigen Jahren
verstorben würde er heute die Tage
angesichts von Jet GPT Dolly 2 und wie
sie alle heißen immer noch solche Bücher
schreiben
oder vielleicht eher Bordcomputers
das können wir jetzt hier nicht
beantworten interessant ist noch die
Anekdote dass er 1967 die erste Mensch
war die gegen ein Schachprogramm
verloren nämlich gegen 6 ja
ist so eine kleine Anekdote findet man
auf Wikipedia ja und jetzt hat er hier
an diesen Aufsatz geschrieben und er
kritisiert jetzt künstliche Intelligenz
von einer anderen Perspektive schon
hatte ist kritisiert aus der Perspektive
von Semantik und Syntax also der
Übergang von logischer zeichnen
Manipulation logischen Regeln hinzu der
Bedeutung einer Sache
er macht das jetzt anders er sagt
intelligence has to be motivated by
purpose in die organism and goals picked
up by the Organismen from on
going culture
Intelligenz gibt es nichts losgelöst nur
in solchen Kisten drin
in solchen Computern wie ich hier ein
vor mir habe und einige von ihnen auch
auf dem Tisch sondern damit wirklich
nicht nur simulierte Intelligenz
entsteht dann er spricht jetzt hier von
der duplication oder real realization
auf Orange intelligence dazu müsste
etwas
motiviert sein durch Zwecke in einem
Organismus und Zwecken oder Zielen die
aus einer Kultur einer Umgebung heraus
aufgenommen als Intelligenz sagt er ist
nicht möglich wenn Intelligenz nicht
eingebettet ist in Kontexte der Kultur
und Kontexte des Lebens ja Lebewesen
setzen sich selbst Zwecke theologisch
hier handelt es sich aber nur um
künstliche Systeme die in keinem
kulturellen Kontext stehen und die nicht
verkörpert sind auch noch ein wichtiger
Punkt die haben keinen Körper keine
Außenseite kann Austausch Medium
und sie haben auch keine Zwecke sie sind
nicht organisch erfasst sie sind keine
Lebewesen damit wir wirkliche künstliche
Intelligenz her haben könnten oder
starke KI sagt drei Fuß müsste es sich
um lebendige künstlichen Intelligenz
Handeln ja jetzt kann man hier
verschiedene Formen von KI rückblickend
unterscheiden symbolverarbeitende KI das
ist die KI von der John Sir gesprochen
hatte
symbolverarbeitende KI manipuliert
Zeichen und verarbeitet Information nach
logischen Regeln und Schlüssen
gewissermaßen deduktiv so war das damals
auch bei die Blue diesen Schachcomputer
der Gary casparoff besiegt hat den hat
man noch in einer Pause gefüttert mit
Daten mit Partien da ja der hat deduktiv
aber der hatte die allgemeine Regel und
er hatte konkrete Fälle und er hat dann
immer versucht zu deduzieren auf den
konkreten Fall hin Angesicht seiner
riesen
Library ist eine riesen
Datenbank die in ihm sich befand also
wurden viele Spiele eingespeist
sozusagen
sollte aber deduzieren also von
allgemeinen Prinzipien logischen Regeln
etwas für konkrete Situation sagen wie
sie sich auch in Schach spielen Stellen
Beispiel ist der Großrechner damals und
der Schachcomputer sind deduktive
Systeme symbolverarbeiten kann der
Vorteil solche Systeme ist dass sie
eindeutig und nachvollziehbare Regeln
haben sie können diese logischen
Schlüsse ganz klar deduktiv ableiten es
gibt es Prinzip und dann gibt es die
Prämissen und die Konklusion das
rational ziemlich eindeutig also es ist
absolut eindeutig das Problem ist die
sind ziemlich stark und wenig flexibel
sie müssen da immer wieder Daten
nachliefern sie müssen es anpassen sie
müssen vielleicht neue verfeinerte
Algorithmen einspielen ähm das ist
ziemlich stark flexibel dagegen gibt es
jetzt neuerdings die neuronalen Netze
die gibt's auch schon länger und Hubert
drei Fuß hat sich damit beschäftigt und
er hat es den Konnektionismus genannt
Konnektionismus deswegen weil es hier um
die Verbindungen geht
konditionistische Systeme neuronale
Netze die liegen allen diesen KI
Phänomen zugrunde die wir gerade
diskutieren Chat GPT Spracherkennung
aber auch dalito alle diese ki-systeme
die sind auf Basis von neuronalen Netzen
entwickelt worden die lernen auf Basis
von empirischen Daten gewissermaßen
induktiv also die beginnt nicht mit den
allgemeinen logischen Gesetzen regeln
sondern die destillieren solche
allgemeinprinzipien erst anhand von
einer Datenbasis heraus also
gewissermaßen von unten nach oben
vollziehen die sich und nicht wie die
deduktive a oder die symbolverarbeitende
KI von oben vom allgemein zum konkreten
hier ist eben Beispiel Google
Spracherkennung auch autonome Fahrzeuge
und Chat GPT die funktioniert mit
solchen neuronalen Netzen der Vorteil
davon ist die sind sehr flexibel und die
haben lernen Effekte wenn Sie die
Datenbasis ändert können die sich wieder
selbst korrigieren die können sich immer
Anpassen an veränder in der Umgebung ein
Nachteil solche Systeme ist dass die
Ergebnisse immer nur wahrscheinlich sind
nicht absolut gewiss deduktiv gewiss wie
bei der symbolverarbeitenden die nur
wahrscheinlich sind nur
Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung und sie
sind nicht nachvollziehbar weil die
Prozesse die zu den Ergebnissen geführt
haben viel zu komplex und zu vernetzt
sind das zeige ich jetzt gleich mal ein
anderes Beispiel schauen wir uns die
neuronalen jetzt an das sind diese
Neuronen und sie sehen hier müssen genau
gar nicht näher darauf eingehen ich will
damit nur sagen es sind sehr komplexe
vernetzungsprozesse die hier stattfinden
ist es gibt hier eine ausgabeschicht und
wenn Sie hier zurück wollen und schauen
wollen wie komme ich hier zurück wie
kann ich das die Ausgabe erklären da
können Sie dann nur sagen das ist mir zu
kompliziert hier wird alles miteinander
vernetzt das und Sie müssen sich das mit
1000 solcher Neuron vorstellen nicht nur
mit drei oder vier also es geht um die
Vernetzung die ist so komplex dass sie
das nicht mehr wirklich nachvollziehen
können hier haben sind Beispiel die gebe
ich mit der Hand die Zahl Sieben ein
das ist der Input hier die Zahl 2 und
dann wird das praktisch durch permutiert
nach hinten und hier hinten wird dann
detektiert die zwei wie die 7 wird auch
richtig erkannt hier unten das ist
neuronalen Netz Erkenntnis und das sehen
Sie die vernetzt hier alles ist das sind
alles diese kleinen Lieder sind alles
Vernetzung wenn sie jetzt fragen wie
kommst du auf die sieben dann muss
dieses System an alles rückgängig
erklären ja wie es hier die Vernetzung
gemacht hat und das ist nicht mehr
irgendwie
verständlicher das ist nicht
verständlich wie etwa
eine deduktive Logik hier sieht man
jetzt das ähm was falsch erkannt wurde
das 55
ist richtig die richtige Zuordnung und
dann sehen wir jetzt aber gleich eine
falsche Eingabe 44 ist auch richtig hier
das wurde falsch erkannt und dann wird
es zurück gespielt das sind dann back
properation Fehler Rückführung und so
trainiert sich das System dann immer
besser ein es wird immer lernt immer
mehr Zeichen zu erkennen auch wenn sie
nicht ganz klar geschrieben sind dabei
handelt sich aber immer um
Wahrscheinlichkeit Verteilung also sehen
wie komplex das ist das sind die Netze
es geht vor und zurück die Neuronen hier
werden miteinander verbunden das ähnelt
schon ein bisschen unserem Gehirn es
soll auch ursprünglich unserem Gehirn
nachempfunden worden sein und jetzt kann
man sich fragen wie sollen wir KI
überhaupt verstehen ist KI eine Technik
eine Technologie
ist KI ein Werkzeug ein Instrument
ist KI ein Medium
ist keine ein Objekt eine Maschine
ist KI sogar ein Subjekt vielleicht
sogar ein autonomes Subjekt
ist KI ein Prozess das schließt sich
auch gar nicht gegenseitig aus ist KI
ein Struktur oder ist KI sogar eine
Erweiterung des Menschen oder seiner
Vermögen
kann man für alles hier treffen wir
Argumente finden ich will ihn nur so
eine Bandbreite an möglichen
philosophischen
Interpretationsmöglichkeiten geben wie
wir diese Phänomene verstehen können es
gibt natürlich auch wie immer
problematische Position von KI so
scheint sie mir jedenfalls es gibt
einerseits die Ideologisierung von KI
ähm sie haben bestimmt schon was von der
transhumanistisch futurologischen
Silicon Valley Ideologie gehört Ray
kurzweilig nach oben rechts auch ein
Link rein zu dem Video der sagt
irgendwann gibt's die Singularität im
Jahr 2100 die Singularität da hat der
technologische Fortschritt so ein Fahrt
aufgenommen dass es zu einem
exponentiellen Wachstum kam als eine
ganz steile beschleunigte Entwicklung
und im Jahr 2100 oder 2051 ist die
technologische Entwicklung so rasant
dass ein neuer Zustand Eintritt der von
allen vorherigen Zuständen völlig
verschieden ist das nennt er die
Singularität
und in dieser Singularität wird dann
künstlich Intelligenz Selbstbewusstsein
erlangen also da wird dann stark KI
realisiert werden da werden künstliche
Systeme nicht mehr nur simulieren
sondern sie werden es eigenständig
realisieren sie werden mentale Zustände
haben es werden Gefühle haben und so
weiter weil Kurzweil geht noch weiter er
sagt es wird dazu führen dass Mensch und
Maschine miteinander verschmelzen das
also künstliche Intelligenz und
biologisches Leben miteinander eine
Einheit eingehen aber das ist dann sagt
er der nächste Schritt der Evolution
bisher war Evolution nur biologisch und
wenn die Singularität kommt wird eine
Evolution stattfinden zwischen Biologie
und Technologie das ist eine neue Form
von Techno Evolution sagt er spannendes
Thema Mario oben rechts den Link rein
kann man sich dann auf Youtube noch
genauer nachschauen auch die
anthropomorphisierung von KI ist
problematisch wenn man unter einem
Roboter eine wirkliche Person versteht
wir neigen aber immer dazu ki-leistungen
auf menschliche Leistung hinzu lesen das
nennt man die anthropomatisierung also
als ob es ein Mensch wäre da haben wir
einfach die Tendenz dazu ich glaube aber
auch wir müssen aufpassen mit der
Banalisierung von KI als bloßes
Hilfsmittel als technologisches
handphänomen das wäre in meinen Augen zu
schwach weil KI doch tatsächlich immer
mehr Eingang unseren Alltag findet es
nur als so ein Rand Phänomen abzutun
kann jetzt vielleicht noch gemacht
werden aber wir werden anhand der
Entwicklung von Jet GPT sehen wird es
irgendwann sehr sehr starken Einfluss
haben und es wird nicht mehr bloß als
Hilfsmittel wahrscheinlich verstanden
werden können als Teil unserer
lebenswert das heißt aber nicht dass wir
es irgendwann mit ähm der der
Singularität zu tun bekommen müssen das
ist sowieso ein ganz ganz problematische
Behauptung dass sie plötzlich was neues
auftritt wenn die KI sich so und so
weiter entwickelt dann entsteht
irgendwann
blitzartig im ergentmäßig ein neues
Phänomen das ist sehr sehr problematisch
und sehr
spekulativ und auch die Dramatisierung
scheint mir nicht angemessen zu sein
dass man jetzt hier die Menschheit in
Gefahr sieht man kann sicherlich darüber
diskutieren ob durch die künstlichen
Intelligenz irgendwann Arbeitsplätze
gefährdet sind sie haben vielleicht die
Debatte mitbekommen viele Künstlerinnen
und Künstler waren entsetzt als ein KI
generiertes Bild einen Kunstpreis
gewonnen hat können Sie nachlesen ja
dann haben die gesagt die KI hat doch
letztendlich von uns geklaut woher
bezieht sie denn die Gehalte die
Datenbasis ja wahllos aus geklauten
Bildern von uns und auf dieser Basis hat
sie dann was neues generiert ist doch
Betrug ja wie diskutieren gleich drüber
ob das vielleicht schon früher so war
dass viele einfach auch von der
Tradition beeindruckt waren viele
künstlerische Künstler und praktisch
auch nur von der Tradition zehren macht
da keine letztendlich was ganz anderes
das sind spannende Fragen und über die
werden wir jetzt ganz ganz kontrovers
mit Pro und Contra Argumenten
diskutieren